je vous le disais en titre Amboise les
conseils municipaux ne ressemblent à
aucun autre l'arrivée de cinq nouveaux
conseillers municipaux n'a pas permis de
dégager une majorité claire hier soir au
contraire elle n'a fait que brouiller
encore un peu plus les cartes entre
majorité mouvante et ordre du jour à la
Prévert faustineau avec les la Turquie
le conseil municipal a duré jusque tard
dans la nuit et dans le climat politique
tendu qui règne à Amboise ceux de
février 211 délibérations soumises au
vote était à l'ordre du jour c'est lourd
c'est qu'on s'est municipaux très long
bien sûr puisque le conseil en son temps
on fait le choix de supprimer un certain
nombre de pouvoirs du maire c'est la
répercussion je ne peux pas faire
autrement donc j'assume et j'applique la
loi tout simplement la séance a débuté
avec la nomination de cinq nouveaux
conseillers municipaux pour remplacer
les démissionnaires un moment crucial
qui devait déterminer si le maire allait
récupérer la majorité perdu en septembre
dernier sur les cinq arrivants 3 étaient
présents et ont pris la parole pour
annoncer leur refus de rejoindre le
maire
et en beaucoup de calcul politique nous
faisons le souhait de ne pas siéger aux
côtés de tirer une table et de ses
conseillers le but de notre déclaration
c'était d'annoncer très très clairement
notre position vis-à-vis de la situation
où le maire a perdu 11 de ses élus donc
5 ans récemment démissionné comme ne
voulait pas s'associer à cette à cette
communauté on va dire puisque on ne sait
pas s'il y a majorité ou minorité
puisque là il y a deux personnes qui
sont en pointillés avec avec des
procurations on a décidé donc d'avoir
une ligne directrice A3 sur les
délibérations
et ont aligné leur vote avec
l'opposition sur les points les plus
attendus car si la majorité des
délibérations ont été adoptées une bonne
nouvelle à première vue pour le maire
Thierry Boutard a finalement été remis
en minorité lors de deux votes à
bulletin secret portant sur les finances
17 voies contre 16 cette majorité
mouvante n’éclaircit donc pas le paysage
politique amboisien je crois que ce soir
ce qu'on observe c'est surtout une
majorité totalement artificielle
d'ailleurs si vous comptez ce soir le
nombre d'élus dans l'opposition nous
sommes en majorité ce soir en présentiel
donc faut pas avoir juste une logique
comptable des choses qui se passe en
boîte c'est grave c'est une ville qui
est aujourd'hui dans une impasse
politique une impasse politique qui
pourrait perdurer alors que le budget
doit être voté à la fin du mois de mars